i think still images still
occupy a place of ultimate importance in
our common language and our common
understanding of the world we live in
[Music]
my name is stephanie reynolds and i'm a
photographer based in washington dc
my name is victor blue
i'm a photographer
and i was inside the u.s capitol on
january 6th
my assignment on january 6 was to cover
the electoral college vote count inside
the house chamber
my assignment on january 6th was to
cover the
large stop the steel rally organized by
former president donald trump
i've covered
demonstrations and protests in this
country and others for
you know many many years
um i'd never seen that level of
uh not just vitriol but that level of
violence directed at law enforcement
officers before and i knew it was
beginning to get dangerous
after the first set of lawmakers
objected to the election results
we left the house chamber to file photos
when we heard that protesters had
started climbing the inauguration stands
outside
i grabbed my cameras
and left the gallery to see if i could
make any photos from inside the capitol
there was a large group of protesters
right at the doors pushing against
capitol police and we started making
photos through the windows
and it was the level of chaos uh was was
just unbelievable it was hard to figure
out what was going on and what wasn't
at one point i got a message from a
reporting thread that said there were
breaches
on the east side on the on the far side
of the capitol and so i and a couple of
colleagues of mine gathered ourselves
and raced over there
we
entered
the columbus doors the very very front
doors up the stairs on the east side of
congress with the protesters who had
bashed them open assaulted the police
who were guarding them and pushed their
way through we were caught up swept up
in the crowd
and shoved directly into
the
right into right under the rotunda of
congress
we weren't aware that people had gotten
into the building until we heard them
pounding on the doors to the house
chamber
guards were barricading the doors and i
kept my lines glued to them while trying
to scan the crowd to see how lawmakers
were reacting
capital police had actually run out of
chemical irritants
pepper spray mace and so at some point
they were spraying
fire extinguishers just white powder
fire extinguishers out the doors to try
to keep the crowd at bay which was
not having
any real effect and a protester
kind of stood on the stairs above the
crowd
he was wearing a suit and a face mask
and he kind of spread his arms out
almost in a cross and a kind of
triumphant gesture wide
um and looked out over the crowd clearly
satisfied and excited by
what they had managed to accomplish and
so i made the picture and it seemed to
resonate a lot with um with readers and
it was published pretty widely a lot was
going through my mind when i took this
photo
regards removing everyone in the house
chamber to one side of the balcony and
telling them to get underneath the seats
as we were being moved i turned and saw
the guards at the door with their guns
drawn and i knew that i needed to plant
my feet take a breath and get the
picture
i think the pictures that we made on
january 6th are are are vitally
important they're vitally important
um as uh evidence of the
of the history we've just gone through
um
of
of the the culminating uh act
of the four years of of the trump
presidency
i became a photojournalist in order to
communicate the the events of our times
to people who couldn't be there to help
and not to help us understand
the forces both inside and outside our
control and to help people understand
each other
uh
better than they could otherwise
i think everyone's work was an important
component to telling the full story of
what went on that day
it was nearly impossible to be
everywhere on your own if you were in
the house chamber you were stuck there
and if you were outside you weren't
getting in
so having teammates who were in
different spots with different
perspectives was incredibly important to
conveying the full story of what
happened